la ecuación del plano que contiene a la
línea recta y nos dan esta ecuación de
la línea recta y que es perpendicular al
plano que contiene a las líneas rectas y
otra vez nos dan sus ecuaciones tenemos
x entre 3 igual a y entre 4 igual a 7
entre 2 y también tenemos la ecuación x
x entre 4 igual a y entre 2 igual a 73
estas dos son líneas y nos preguntan
cuál es esa ecuación muy bien entonces
solo para tener muy claro qué es lo que
estamos haciendo voy a hacer algunos
dibujos de cómo se ven todos estos
planos entonces primero el plano que
queremos encontrar digamos más o menos
puede que se vea así por supuesto no voy
a hacer digamos no ni siquiera voy a
poner las los ejes en el espacio porque
realmente no los necesito sólo quiero
visualizar qué es lo que estamos
haciendo entonces este es el plano que
queremos encontrar y nos dicen que este
este plano contiene una línea ahora a
partir de este momento voy a utilizar
notación vectorial porque al menos en
cabeza queda muchísimo más claro cómo
manipular estos objetos geométricos y
además de que es más fácil trabajar con
ellos ok digo por supuesto puede haber
otras formas ok
quizás no se deforma algebraica o qué sé
yo pero al menos de forma vectorial se
entiende muy bien qué es lo que vamos a
hacer entonces notemos que la línea que
subraya de rojo está contenida en
particular si x y y y ceta son 0
entonces se cumple esta ecuación así que
el 0 x igual a 0 igual a y bueno cuando
x es 0 0 y z también es 0 se cumple la
ecuación y además está en el plano
entonces ahí está el 0 aunque hay de
hecho vamos a ponerle que este es el 0 0
pueden pensarlo como vector de posición
o en fin y nos dicen que debe estar
contenido esta línea ahora fijémonos que
si x es 2 entonces 2 entre 2 es uno y
por lo tanto ya tiene que ser 3 y z
tiene que ser 4 verdad para que todos
nos den 1 entonces el punto 2 3 4
digamos que sea este el punto 2 3 4 está
sobre el plano y si está la línea
entonces están todos los puntos que
conectan al 0 con el 2 3 4
todos estos puntos
bien derechito porque la línea recta
todos estos más o menos digo ok quizás
si los pone pintamos un poco más
derechitos todos estos puntos están
sobre esta línea muy bien entonces
realmente el vector que apunta de 0 al 2
3 4 a quien falta cerrar está contenido
en el plano
es este vector posición muy bien ahora
bien también tenemos que pintar un plano
que es ortogonal a este o es
perpendicular y que contiene estas
líneas entonces pensemos en un plano
perpendicular
muy bien digamos algo así
algo así más o menos
exacto y aquí es en donde intersecta el
plano a este amarillo y este se sigue de
forma perpendicular hacia abajo y hacia
arriba muy bien ahí tenemos más o menos
una imagen de qué es lo que estamos
haciendo y contiene estas líneas la
línea que pasa por algún punto digamos
si x es 3
entonces 3 entre 31 y eso nos obliga o
nos obliga a aquellas 4
iceta es 2 muy bien entonces si si eso
pasa aquí voy a tener digamos el punto 3
4 2 muy bien
y toda esta línea azul que estoy
pintando va a estar contenida en nuestro
plano blanco también eso va a ocurrir si
yo me tomo el punto por ejemplo si x es
entonces ya tiene que ser 2 y z tiene
que ser 3 entonces digamos que sea por
ejemplo este punto de aquí el 4 23
verdad 4 2 3 y toda esta línea debe
estar contenida en este plano muy bien
entonces si utilizamos la anotación
vectorial este vector yo lo puedo
expresar como 2 y más 3 jota más 4 acá
donde hijo take a son nuestros elementos
de la base canónica son el 100 el 0 1 0
y el 0 0 1 muy bien y este digamos vamos
a llamarle a este vector a entonces lo
que voy a hacer con este vector a si nos
damos cuenta este está contenido en el
plano
entonces si encuentro yo otro plano o
perdón a otro vector contenido en el
plano amarillo entonces puedo puedo
encontrar un producto
vector que sea normal es decir que sea
perpendicular al plano y entonces la
ecuación del plano quedará dado en el
producto punto de ese vector normal con
el resto sí esto a lo mejor no tiene
sentido para ti más o menos quedará más
claro a medida que vayamos avanzando
pero una vez que ya tenemos estos dos
vectores que por cierto están contenidos
en el plano este este vector dirección o
este vector posición digamos a éste
vamos a llamarle vamos a llamarle be ok
este es el b es igual al 4 y más 2 jota
más 3 acá que y este es el vector b y al
otro vamos a llamarle el vector c
el vector ce es igual al 3 y más 4 j más
2 k muy bien y por supuesto recordemos
que nuestro objetivo es encontrar la
ecuación del plano amarillo muy bien
entonces ahora que ya tenemos veis lo
que nosotros podemos hacer es vamos a
vamos a recordar la estrategia
necesitamos encontrar un vector que sea
ortogonal a ellos es decir que sea
perpendicular un vector que sea
perpendicular a ellos necesariamente va
a quedar aquí contenido por ejemplo este
de aquí que le vamos a llamar d si ya
tengo un vector de que está contenido en
el plano amarillo puedo hacer el
producto punto perdón el producto cruz
con este a que ya tenía ambos están en
el plano y eso me dará un vector que es
perpendicular a estos dos y por lo tanto
es un vector normal al plano y entonces
ya podremos tener nuestra ecuación que
nos piden muy bien entonces el objetivo
por ahorita es calcular este producto
cruz
cruz ce
de cruz
y este bueno este es nuestro vector de
verdad el que dijimos que va a estar
dentro del plano amarillo porque es este
vector de va a ser perpendicular estos
dos si no recuerdas muy bien que es el
producto cruz te recomiendo que lo
visites en nuestras listas de álgebra
lineal muy bien ahora que tenemos el
vector de y sabemos cómo calcularlo pues
hay que hacerlo esto se calcula como si
fuera un determinante donde aquí ponemos
y j ica
muy bien calculamos el determinante
ponemos en el primer renglón los digamos
las coordenadas de b que es 4 2 3 4
y 3 y después ponemos las coordenadas de
c que es 342 y calculamos este
determinante vamos a ver que nos da
entonces nuestro vector de será igual a
si nos tomamos y quitamos su renglón y
su columna y nos queda esta sub matriz y
calculamos el determinante dos por dos
es cuatro menos tres por 412 que 12
más bien sería 4 menos 12 son menos 8 y
esto queda en el vector i y ahora
tomamos jota que va a llevar un menos
verdad quitamos columna y renglón y nos
queda el determinante de 4 4 3 3 y 2 y
esto es 4 por 2 son 8 menos 3 por 3 que
son 9 entonces queda 8 menos 9 es menos
1 pero con este menos que llevábamos nos
queda más verdad recuerden que el signo
hay que cambiarlo cuando saltamos
digamos esta posición y ahora nos toca
con el vector acá quitamos renglón y
columna y nos queda 4x4 16 menos dos por
tres que son 6 esto nos da simplemente
10 está muy bien y ya tenemos nuestro
vector de ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
para encontrar un vector que sea normal
al plano amarillo es hacer el producto
cruz entre d ya y eso nos da un vector
aquí digamos que se va a llamar n de
normal
ahora bien vamos a calcular esto
necesitamos calcular
cruz a que éste es nuestro vector que
vamos a llamar n y esto lo podemos
calcular de la misma forma tomamos el
determinante tomamos ahí jota y acá
muy bien tomamos ese determinante aquí
ponemos las coordenadas de de las
coordenadas de d son menos 8 aquí está
en verdad 1 y 10 y ahora tomamos también
las coordenadas de a que son 2 3 y 4
entonces lo único que nos falta es
calcular este producto cruz o más bien
este ya sería este determinante eso nos
da n que es un vector ortogonal o
perpendicular a nuestro plano amarillo y
entonces este como es un vector normal
al hacer el producto punto con
cualquiera que esté en el plano nos debe
dar 0 muy bien y de hecho voy a
continuar
todas estas cuentas en el próximo vídeo
porque tampoco quiero que se hagan muy
largos así que nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo para terminar este problema